He always promised he would be back.
Terminator star Arnold Schwarzenegger and
original Sarah Connor actor Linda Hamilton
are back in action in a batch of new photos
from the upcoming sci-fi sequel, Terminator:
Dark Fate.
One new photo released by the studio shows
a grizzled and bearded Schwarzenegger, as
the T-800 model Terminator, sporting a scar
and giving the stink-eye to someone off camera.
Another depicts Hamilton in character as Sarah
Connor, looking older but no less battle-hardened
with a heavy vest of armor on her chest, and
aviator sunglasses.
Though Terminator: Dark Fate does feature
the two iconic franchise stars, it also brings
several new faces into the fold: Mackenzie
Davis as a soldier-assassin named Grace, Natalia
Reyes as Dani Ramos , Diego Boneta as Miguel
Ramos, and Gabriel Luna as a new type of Terminator.
IGN shared stills of each star new to the
series in action, with shots including
Davis' Grace character staring down an opponent
mid-fight,
Reyes' Dani peeking over her shoulder near
a parked car in the middle of an open field,
Boneta's Miguel affecting a scowl from behind
the wheel of a truck,
and Luna's Terminator dressed in what looks
to be a military uniform while stalking through
some sort of high-tech facility.
Set after the events of T2: Judgment Day,
Dark Fate will effectively do to the Terminator
franchise what 2018's Halloween revival did
with its own series - by pretending most of
the sequels in the series didn't happen.
Instead, Dark Fate is reportedly picking up
at the last point basically everyone agreed
the series was still good.
As a result, the movie won't address the events
of 2003's Terminator 3: Rise of the Machines,
2009's Terminator Salvation, or 2015's much-maligned
Terminator Genisys - likely for the better.
As producer David Ellison once said of the
film's focus,
"I will say we have resolved the future of
the franchise, and believe me, it's an incredibly
bright future.
I think where it's going will be the continuation
of what the fans really wanted since T2 … It's
something we're incredibly excited about and
we think is the direction it needs to head."
James Cameron, the director and writer of
the first two films and a longtime series
producer, is also back in the creative mix
for Dark Fate, and he's previously shared
his vision for this transformative sixth movie
in the franchise.
Speaking in an interview in July 2017, Cameron
expressed that the goal with the forthcoming
movie is to pass the narrative baton through
the introduction of new characters, while
also modernizing the doomsday narrative to
reflect current technological anxieties.
He's also aware that the franchise needs a
careful approach to bring it back in line
with the speculative sci-fi ambitions of the
first two movies.
As Cameron phrased it,
"The question is, 'Has the franchise run its
course or can it be freshened up?
Can it still have relevance now, where so
much of our world is catching up to what was
science fiction in the first two films?'"
Despite how important the new characters may
be for evolving and continuing the Terminator
series, Dark Fate director Tim Miller says
that Linda Hamilton is the most vital piece
of this movie's puzzle.
He explained to IGN that Hamilton returning
to her role as Sarah Connor made a vision
for the new sequel fall into place for him,
and that her presence helps bridge the gap
between past franchise entries and installments
that are yet to come.
"You think you're safe and alive?
You're already dead.
Everybody.
Him, you - you're dead already."
The director said, "The fact that Linda came
back makes this particular Terminator fresh.
This story could only continue with her in
the role of Sarah Connor.
That's the most important thing for me.
Linda reinvented this character in a way that
both honors who she was before and brings
something new to the role."
He also gave major kudos to the new cast,
all of whom he says hold their own and bring
something new to the table while sharing the
screen with Hamilton and Schwarzenegger.
Miller also teased the movie's focus on character
over big-budget spectacle, investing audiences
in the cast before putting them all in peril.
He said,
"We have a lot of powerful, moving character
moments up front, but toward the back half
of the movie, when s--- gets going [...] it
just doesn't stop.
And we tried very hard to make it all different
and fresh - it's not just people punching
each other; it's a roller coaster ride and
I think [it's] great."
Fans can watch as old-school meets new-school
when Terminator: Dark Fate arrives in theaters
on November 1.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.